Welcome to Module Eight — natural language processing.
The journey here is from raw text to tensors a network can learn from.
We'll cover tokenization, embeddings, recurrent networks, and attention.
First you have to turn text into numbers.
Word-level tokens are simple but explode your vocabulary.
Character-level keeps the vocabulary tiny but the sequences long.
Subword schemes — BPE, WordPiece, SentencePiece — are the sweet spot, and modern language models live on roughly thirty to two-hundred thousand of them.
But an integer ID carries no meaning, so we embed it.
One-hot vectors are sparse and blind.
Word2Vec learns from local co-occurrence with Skip-gram and CBOW; GloVe factorizes a global count matrix.
The famous result — king minus man plus woman lands near queen — shows the geometry actually captures meaning, and pretrained embeddings give your downstream tasks a head start.
To handle order, recurrent networks read a sequence one step at a time.
A SimpleRNN forgets, its gradient vanishing over long spans.
The LSTM adds a gated cell that protects long-term state; the GRU does nearly as well with fewer parameters.
Wrap either to read bidirectionally, and remember to mask your padding.
Then comes the idea that changed everything: attention.
Compare a query against keys to get similarity scores, softmax them into weights, and take a weighted sum of the values — a context vector that decides where to look.
Scale by the square root of d-k for stability, and run several heads in parallel to capture different relationships at once.
Put it to work on real tasks — sentiment as sequence-to-class, named entity recognition at the token level, autoregressive text generation, and encoder–decoder translation.
And in practice today, you'd start from BERT, GPT, or T5 weights.
Let's build an attention model from scratch — open the labs.